vous voulez savoir n'est ce pas pourquoi
ils persistent à venir ici sur terre
ils ont les autres ce que vous cacher je
le vends pas mes amis
au monde se meurt optimus prime
[Musique]
cherches tu l'arrêt d'anciens we may cry
4 us de la faire
[Musique]
il s'est dit à travers les âges
que son sacrifice il n'y a pas de
victoire
[Musique]
deux espèces en guerre
l'une de serre l'autre de métal
optimus prime nous a quittés 100
milliards 2 millions de planètes dans le
cosmos
[Musique]
non
vous voulez savoir la soirée pourquoi il
persiste à venir ici
[Musique]
je veux rester
et je veux me battre
aujourd'hui de monde entrent en
collision
l'opération est terminée on renonce pas
où tu es
un seul survivra
par deux mois
[Musique]